[Music]
my name is Claire Dearing and I'm the
founder of the dinosaur protection group
so this is a velociraptor so many people
loved Jurassic world and when you say to
them when was the first time that you
saw a dinosaur mm-hmm I mean you just
see them light up dinosaurs are all so
different there are so many different
species of dinosaurs my mission in life
is to ensure the safety and protection
of these animals what are you going to
do to make sure that your children have
the same experience that you did you can
help ensure their survival
go to our website browse around sign up
for our newsletter are you going to be a
part of the generation who decided to
have dinosaurs go extinct or will you be
on board with making sure that dinosaurs
can stay alive for future generations we
must save the dinosaurs
[Music]
you
[Music]
do you remember the first time you saw a
dinosaur
thank blue we don't really believe it
[Music]
it's like a miracle
[Music]
something's coming cuz it's your ex it's
your eyes it's not Rex
[Applause]
a little come with me you know you can't
stay here
Jurassic world the island your honor
easy girl all of that is in the past
come on oh yeah I want to show you the
future what is that thing they made it
[Music]
you need to get us out of here yeah
[Music]
[Music]